[Música]
y es entonces sólo entonces cuando llega
ese momento
el momento de tomar una decisión
lo haces o no lo haces
te arriesgas
venga lo dejó pasar
lo que muchas veces no sabemos es que
esa decisión la hemos tomado unos
minutitos antes
necesito un voluntario
te voy a pedir que pienses un número
vale un número que tú quieras del 5 al
10 o del 1 al 10 por ejemplo ante tu
quiera uno que te guste si solo pensar
y mientras tanto voy sacando esto sabes
lo que es esto
la baraja de cartas baraja de póker
tenéis pinta de de casino
picas corazones tréboles y diamantes si
la sal 10-j cuica la dejo ahí
anna estás pensando número
e
puedes cambiarlo
puedes cambiarlo ya no lo puedes cambiar
por primera vez antes de que yo me
acerca a la baraja qué número estás
pensando
el 7
bueno esperando enseño
fíjate que me voy a acercar por primera
vez a la baraja y que no llevo nada en
las manos nada en las mangas y que voy a
[ __ ] la caja que está desde el
principio aquí no sé si se oye
dentro de la caja hay algo
quiero que veáis que sacó de la caja
cuatro cartas y solo cuatro y que no hay
nada más
claro si decimos que las decisiones
muchas veces las tomamos incluso antes
de lo que pensamos la pregunta no es
porque estos son los 47 es que ha dicho
anna
la pregunta es cómo he podido yo
condicionar la de tal manera para que
incluso antes ella estuviera pensando
exactamente el número 7 y eso es de lo
que hemos venido hoy a hablar aquí así
que muchas gracias por venir
anna dijo un 7 y esto es 17 27 37 y el
hace ya más de diez años que aprendí una
de las lecciones más importantes que me
dio la magia y además una de las
lecciones que pongo en práctica día tras
día
y es que fijaos la magia no ocurre en
las manos de un mago la magia ocurre en
la mente de un espectador solo en ese
momento hay magia pensando de la
siguiente manera la ilusión al final no
se produce por lo que ocurre se produce
por lo que tú te dices qué ocurre se
produce por lo que cada uno de los
espectadores se dice que ocurre os
acordáis de vico perfil cuando hacía
desaparecer la estatua de la libertad
todos sabemos que la estatua de la
libertad no desaparece y sin embargo tú
generas una conversación contigo mismo
en la que dices eso es imposible
ahí es donde imagina
y es ese diálogo interno ese diálogo
interior que tenemos nosotros el que va
a condicionar enormemente la manera que
tenemos de percibir el mundo
la manera que tenemos de interpretarlo y
de dirigirnos hacia él fijaos para mí el
riesgo no es no arriesgar el riesgo es
no hacerlo porque tengamos un diálogo
tan negativo que nos impida ver bueno
las oportunidades que tenemos fuera que
tengamos nos digamos cosas tan negativas
que al final nos impida ver bueno que a
lo mejor hay cosas que nos benefician
allí esa es la verdadera mentira de las
decisiones libres
decíamos eliges con libertad pero es
aparente aparente porque al final tu
toma de decisiones está condicionada
enormemente a lo que te digas cuál es el
problema que muchas veces no somos
conscientes de las cosas que nos decimos
de las palabras que usamos de cómo nos
tratamos y te dices cosas que te limitan
o que te potencian te engañas a ti mismo
te engañas te inventas cosas porque
muchas veces es que creamos realidades
paralelas a quique que solo vemos
nosotros y eso es lo que ocurre con este
juego de magia
de hecho pretendía explicar oslo
creéis juego y si calla calla y explica
pero fijaos os lo quiero explicar para
que veáis como muchas veces los magos
prácticamente no tiene nada que hacer
simplemente ponen un camino en el que tú
te permite o a ti te permite hablarte y
decirte eso es imposible
de hecho fijaos ni os lo voy a explicar
simplemente lo voy a repetir parece
entonces por ejemplo no te importa
piensa un número por ejemplo del 5 al 10
vale y no me digas el 7 que sale ya te
digo yo
lo tienes
qué número estás pensando
fíjate que voy a acercar por primera vez
a la baraja y fíjate que la baraja en la
parte de arriba de la baraja hay 18 28
38 y 48
veis por dónde voy
al final el juego de magia no consistía
en que aparecieran en la caja eso te lo
has dicho tú a ti mismo fijaos si tú
analizas el juego el juego es tan feliz
es un poco o sea tú dime qué número
estás pensando y mágicamente aparece
donde yo quiero
juego de magia espectacular claro si me
dices el 8 están arriba si me dices en 7
aquí los 6 es estando aquí dados las
vueltas
oye qué me dices el 9 no te preocupe
mira tan aquí no os preocupéis está todo
salta todo solucionado
los 5 creo que también los tengo por
aquí o sea todo todo lo tengo controlado
vale
y yo recuerdo que esto lo hacía esto lo
hacía cuando llegaba a casa de mis
amigos a cenar cogió una baraja española
y ponía tres de copas por un lado del 5
de pimiento por ahí y luego preguntaba
dime una carta y me decían el 3 de copas
digo mira en el jarrón
también os digo
si esto lo vais a hacer que posiblemente
lo vais a hacer que nos pase como a mí y
que una vez digamos que ya me pilló un
poco tarde quizá me había tomado un par
de copas
y digamos que cuando dice una carta me
dice en el tres de copas y digo mira en
el jarrón dice aquí hay un dos de bastos
bueno mira en la estanterías porque en
algún lado yo he puesto entre se
compraba le colocó la cordada
fijaos el diálogo interno ese diálogo
que nosotros tenemos va a marcar
enormemente la manera que tenemos de
percibir el mundo pero es que es más va
a marcar la manera que tenemos de
generar emociones ante una misma
situación cada uno de nosotros podemos
generar un diálogo interno distinto que
va a hacer que generemos emociones
totalmente distintas va a condicionar la
manera que tenemos de comportarnos yo
siempre lo digo quieres cambiar tu mundo
empieza a cambiar la manera que tiene de
hablar te quieres ganar mayor seguridad
para tomar más riesgos empieza a cambiar
la manera que tienes de tratarte
os imaginais yo no creo que haya nadie
en el mundo que haya tomado riesgos con
un diálogo negativo
os imaginais a los hermanos wright con
el aeroplano primeras personas que van a
volar y diciéndose buff te mato te mato
me mato me mata me mata me mata me lamía
mira tocas cómo se mueve la tuerca que
me piñón de pinho hombre pues
posiblemente ese día no cogen el aro con
otro
con lo cual chicos deberes teneis
deberes
algunos de las clases ya tenéis deberes
está comprensible con deberes y lo que
os voy a pedir es que simplemente un día
cuando estéis ante esas decisiones que a
todos nos cuesta tomar que de alguna
manera te atraen pero a la vez te dan un
poquito de miedito
quiero que escribáis os pongáis a
escribir y no que escribáis una lista de
pros y contras que es lo que solemos
hacer no no no quiero que escribáis
vuestro diálogo interno ese que os
habéis pillado teniendo con vosotros
mismos vale y que lo escribáis tal cual
no no no lo matices no lo pongáis en
bonito tal cual vale y os voy a pedir
que después lo leáis y lo analices les
hagáis preguntas
te tratas bien cómo me trató estás bien
te tratas mal
qué cosas te dices qué palabras utilizas
contigo mismo te limitas de potencias te
engañas
de hecho una buena medida es [ __ ] ese
diálogo interno y pensar
si eso se lo dirías a la persona que más
queréis en el mundo a la persona que más
queréis ayudar porque muchas veces somos
capaces de decirnos cosas que no le
diríamos a nadie
no sé si os suena esos diálogos de veces
que te lo mereces te lo mereces que más
te tendrían que dar incluso nos decimos
cosas que no le permitiremos a nadie que
nos dijeron a nosotros es que tú no
vales que no te va a salir déjalo no lo
intentes
y os aseguro que eso va a empezar a
marcar vuestra manera de generar
comportamientos y lo tercero que voy a
pedir es que escribáis ese diálogo nos
escribáis como debería ser os estoy
diciendo que os engañéis no estoy
diciendo que lo pinte jce en un mundo de
rosa no estoy diciendo que os habéis con
respeto que os cuidáis que utilicéis las
palabras que os mereceis y que al final
si estamos diciendo que bueno vamos a
tomar decisiones importantes
hagamos útil ese diálogo cuidaros cuidar
nuestro diálogo interno
y de hecho me vais a permitir que
acabemos con un pequeño experimento
parece voy a pedir que os recortes hacia
atrás que os pongáis cómodos en vuestra
silla
y os voy a pedir que cerráis los ojos
cerrando los ojos eso es y cerrando los
ojos bien cuidado con las carteras y
cerrar los ojos bien y os voy a pedir
que os contentéis en dos cositas primera
cosa que es concéntrese en vuestra
respiración vale hacer una respiración
larga
inspirada
y aspirar es simplemente
aguanta da esa tranquilidad
y simplemente que os empecéis a
concentrar en mi voz porque me vais a
permitir que durante los dos próximos
minutillos sea vuestro diálogo interno o
sea bueno pues ese diálogo que va a
guiar la manera que tiene de generar
emociones de comportarte si lo vamos a
hacer en una situación muy concreta
quiero que penséis en ese viaje el viaje
todos tenemos ese viaje ese viaje
deseado por un lado pero en cierta
manera ha tenido ese que no nos hemos
atrevido a hacer no quiero que penséis
en el de bueno no lo hago por dinero
nombre ya así no no hablo el de cinco
estrellas hoteles de cinco estrellas no
hablo de ese que bueno en cierta manera
te atrae pero también te genera miedo te
genera angustia que genera inseguridad
y quiero que penséis y concentres en
este diálogo que os voy a plantear
bueno si apetece me apetece ir
y si me pasa algo no es que la cultura
es muy distinta son culturas muy
distintas y al final lo que es normal
aquí lo mismo allí no es tan normal
normal comida normal que ya me han dicho
que allí lo de comer normal nada ahí
puesto por la calle ya saber si lo que
te estás comiendo está vivo o muerto
acaba rezando por tener algo que meterte
en la boca que sea para por lo menos
apoyo bueno espera espera espera espera
un ojo
en serio esto sí es importante esto es
que a mí me da mucho fue un amigo hace
poco me dijo que la gente es muy
intolerante que al final vas por la
calle y si no eres de los suyos te miran
así qué necesidad tienes tú a tu edad de
meterte en líos de meterte en follones
por dios con lo tranquilito que estás en
casa por favor
y además si ya me cuesta que me
entiendan en mi idioma como para que me
entiendan en el idioma de estos se les
entiende y si me meto en líos y no se
ven y pedir ayuda y si me pierdo bueno y
si me roban pero espera espera peor y si
me secuestran que ahí los secuestros
están a la orden del día
na na na na na na
no abras los ojos vale
solo pensar que tal lo sentís si es el
momento de venga a compra el billete
y ahora pensar en el siguiente diálogo
de acuerdo
a ver a ver a ver
pero con lo que me apetece es como no
voy a ir con lo que me apetece y si me
pasa algo si me pasa hoy aquí también me
puede pasar algo y qué hago
me escondo que además que no voy solo
que la gente malo será que nos pase a
todos lo mismo al final nos apoyamos
unos entre otros y además que voy a
estar todo el rato con él y sí sí sí sí
sí me mata y si me secuestra dirime y si
me cae una maceta andando por la calle
que ha cometido en casa por nombre no
claro que voy a conocer otras culturas
que de eso se trata
para conocer lo de siempre ya me quedo
en casa y chicos pues mira si no me
gusta poco no volver pues ya está
leche es que me lo merezco es que me lo
merezco precisamente por la edad que
tengo me lo merezco que ya está bien
toda la vida igual que voy a dejar que
todo que todo sea condicionado por el
miedo que nombre que no ya tengo una
edad que son muchos años que sigue ahora
estudia la carrera de al buscado trabajo
hoy no tienes pareja pero cásate hoy el
niño pero todavía sigues como no te
divorcias en a hombre ya está bien se
acabó que no que es que me lo merezco y
me lo merezco y lo voy a hacer porque me
lo merezco porque lo voy a disfrutar y
porque quiero porque al final en el
fondo si no quisiera no estaría teniendo
esta conversación
podéis abrir los ojos
qué tal
se nota la diferencia
y fijaos es tan importante porque es
después de esta conversación después de
esta conversación cuando llega la
situación con la que hemos empezado la
conferencia os acordáis
y es entonces cuando llega el momento
ese momento de decidir de tomar una
decisión lo hago o no lo hago
me arriesgo o lo dejó ir
y lo cierto es que la decisión habíamos
tomado unos minutos antes y sabes qué
que depende de ti muchas gracias
[Aplausos]